hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about head injuries what to do if you
have a head injury now this is an
acupressure technique okay and you're
gonna need someone to do this on you so
the person that's doing it should be
watching the video to go ahead and walk
you through it here's the principle
there's many different things that can
happen to the head you can actually have
a car accident where your front end of
your head hits the windshield or the
back part or a blow to the skull or
falling on the top of the head you name
it all sorts of things can happen to the
skull there are little joints in the
skull right through here down here
called sutures and believe it or not
there's a lot of tension that can build
up in the skull even around these
sutures long after the injury so here
you already got hit in the head with
something 20 years ago and it's still
being a problem in the form of a kind of
a heaviness a headache tension and so
this technique can give you a lot of
relief okay you just got to try it so
the first thing you're going to do is
just kind of for general head injuries
you're gonna take the thumb and you're
gonna press forward up to and I'm gonna
just show you so you're gonna press
upward okay this way okay so you're
gonna just press upward and hold the
front of the head and lift upward and
hold that for maybe I don't know 10
seconds okay and then you get a slowly
inch up 10 more seconds inch up 10 more
seconds and I'm pressing this way and
you're pushing like all this old stress
up to the center of the head okay you're
pressing up this way and you just spend
your time and you push upward this way
now the person is going to get a lot of
relief they're going to feel really good
and they're gonna get a sense of relief
and more space in their skull okay so
you're going to keep going up through
here inching all the way until you get
to the front okay
so that's the first technique now if you
had injury to a part of the head let's
say right here what you want to do that
the injuries right here you want to
press into the injury
this way from different angles okay so
you're just going to press in this way
that way with that force and you're
going to hold that for you know a few
minutes and then press this way okay so
if you press in there it's going to help
kind of release that tension that stuck
tension in the head the other thing you
want to do if you got hit right here for
example you want to press on the
opposite side
okay the opposite side the mirror image
side so wherever you got hit on this
side you press on the opposite side and
that will give you a lot of relief okay
that's the next thing you do if you get
hit right on the top of the head you're
not going to press them the opposite so
you're gonna go towards the injury okay
this way this way and this way and this
way you're going to hold that right
through in there now if you actually got
hit in the nose or the eyebrows or the
forehead you can press your thumb down
this way and press it all the way into
this way right through in here press it
down okay a lot of times I'll see people
that have scars right here or here
because of an old injury to the head you
can press on the opposite side I'm
telling you this gives the people a
tremendous amount of relief if you get
hit in the nose you want to press into
the nose so the bones that attach to the
cartilage right through here you want to
press through here to here up into the
injury okay
Dental same thing press down into the
teeth through here okay so those are
some simple things you can do to the
skull to give people a tremendous amount
of relief you're going to find that
they're gonna sleep better they're gonna
actually feel calmer they're gonna
reduce their stress all right go ahead
and try this and comment below
hey guys I want to talk about these two
books right here okay I want to explain
it this book right here is a very short
book it explains why to do keto and how
to do it it's filled with pictures you
can get through this in 45 minutes real
quick just very important to know the
details the basics of how to do it now
this book the new body type guide should
have been called be on keto because I
rarely find someone that has just a
weight problem they usually have a lot
of other body problems and in this book
I cover all the reasons why keto and
intermittent fasting might not work for
you we go into the body types we go into
inflammation we go into stress hardcore
and what to do about it so if you want
to maximize your results you definitely
want to get this one right here okay so
my goal is to get you to do keto
correctly what I mean by that is do it
healthily
it's called healthy ketosis so we can
avoid all the issues that happen with
transitioning the fat burning keto flu
kita fatigue keto rash kidney stones
gout etc and right now on my website if
you get this you get this at no extra
cost
I put a link down below check it out